leave I won't be offended
okay so uh today I'm going to talk about
our work on Parallel batch Dynamic uh K4
decomposition this is Joint work with
Juan con Leo Jessica
you've heard a little bit about this
work in Quan Quan's talk earlier in this
Workshop but I'll provide some more
details and also go over some
experimental results
thank you
it seems like the clicker is not working
um
okay
um so first of all graphs are becoming
very large today the largest public
available graph has over 100 billion
edges
um and this craft represents just a
small fraction of the websites on the
internet
and there are proprietary graphs out
there that are even larger with orders
of trillions of edges
for there were many real world graphs
are rapidly changing as we all know for
example on the Twitter Network there are
about 500 million new tweets per day and
on the internet there are over 500 000
new websites created every day and these
events correspond to updates to our
graph
so in order to process these massive and
dynamic graphs we use parallelism as
well as Dynamic algorithms so we want to
design algorithms that can take
advantage of the multiple processing
units on almost all modern machines
today and of course we want to design
Dynamic algorithms to avoid unnecessary
work on these updates
so our work focuses on this parallel
batch Dynamics setting which you've
heard several times already but just as
a reminder in this setting we're getting
our updates and batches and we can use
parallelism within each batch to speed
things up
okay so pictorially we're getting
batches of edge insertions into
deletions you can also deal with
vertices but I'm just going to talk
about edges for this talk
we also have a current graph as well as
some statistics we want to try to
maintain about the graph such as the
triangle counts the page ranks and so on
and we want to be able to efficiently
generate this updated graph as well as
the statistics uh updated statistics so
we want to delete the edges that we
don't want anymore we want to add the
edges that we want and then we want to
like update our triangle counts or page
ranks efficiently
Okay so
uh We've looked at a variety of problems
in this parallel batch Dynamic setting
most of these are graph problems but
we've also looked at the closest pair
problem which is a problem from
computational geometry
and for all these problems we were able
to come up with a theoretically
efficient algorithms in terms of how
much work they do and how much
parallelism they have and for some of
the pro these problems we also
implemented them and showed that they
run efficiently in practice on Modern
machines on real world data sets so
today I'm going to focus on one of these
results which is the k-core
decomposition result
I do want to mention that there has been
a bunch of related work on designing
algorithms in this parallel bash Dynamic
setting so people have looked at
triangle counting or La Tour trees
connected components uh Ray compressed
trees as well as
incremental minimum spanning trees and
some of these papers uh include guy
Blalock and lushman duapala they're not
here but they told me they're going to
be watching the stream so I made sure to
put their citations
okay so uh let me let me Define the
k-core decomposition problem
um so a k coordinate graph is a maximal
connected subgraph such that all the
vertices have induced degree at least K
so if we only consider the neighbors
that are in the subgraph we want to have
at least K Neighbors
and the coordinates of a Vertex V is the
largest value of K such that V
participates in the k core
so in this example graph these four
vertices that I've circled here on the
are in the Three core
uh you can check that they all have
induced degree at least three and
furthermore if I added any other vertex
uh to this Three core any other subset
of vertices it would no longer be a
three core somebody would have degree
less than three
all of these vertices in the in the
bigger blob are in the two core again
you can check everyone has degree at
least two and if I were to add this last
vertex to this two chord it would no
longer be a two chord because this loss
vertex has degree one and finally the
entire graph is in the one core
and now the coordinates of that vertex V
that I've labeled is three it
participates in the one chord two chord
and the three chord and three is the
largest value of K
so the goal of this problem is to
compute the coordinates values for all
the vertices in the graph
once you have the coordinates values you
can easily extract a k-core for a
particular value of K just by running
connected components on the appropriate
subset of vertices
any questions about the definition
okay so it turns out that exact k-core
decomposition is pretty hard to
parallelize and furthermore in many
applications you don't really need an
exact k-core decomposition so we decided
to look at this approximate keyboard
decomposition problem
um so the definition of k-core is still
the same it's just that these
coordinates values we return are
approximate so uh we return these C
approximate coordinates values where the
values are within a multiplicative C
factor of the true coordinates
let's say I assigned a coordinates value
of approximate coordinates value of 3 to
everything in that gray blob and then
approximate corners of two to that last
vertex and the three yellow vertices
would have a three halves approximation
because their true coordinates is two
and I gave them an approx coordinates of
three and then the green vertex has a
two approximation because I gave it an
approx coordinates of two but it's true
coordinates is one
okay so our goal is to try to maintain
these C approximate coordinates values
uh for uh appropriate value of C uh yes
question
um
yeah so that's a good question so a
question was in the offline setting
um how do you solve this problem so it
turns out that in the offline setting
there's an easy peeling algorithm as you
suggested where you just repeatedly
delete the vertices with the minimum
degree and when you delete the vertex uh
like whatever value of K you're looking
at when you delete the vertex then you
assign a coordinates of K to that vertex
and then if there are no more vertices
with degree at most k then you increment
K and then you repeat until the whole
graph is uh empty yes
is that unique yeah so everybody has a
unique core number coordinates value
yeah
to both directions when you consider
approximation yeah yeah so this is a uh
yeah two-sided approximation yeah
the healing algorithm solves it exactly
but it's not parallel it's not uh
theoretically parallel because
um there are certain graphs where you
just have to appeal for a linear number
of rounds and then you don't get any
parallel speed up for example if you
just imagine like a chain like the two n
vertices of degree one and everyone else
has degree two then you just keep
peeling off the two ends of the chain
and you need a linear number of rounds
yeah so it is a no known parallel
algorithm for it
well the getting better than a two
approximation for exact k-core is well
okay getting better than a two
approximation for k-core is p complete
so there's a proof showing that like
it's very unlikely that you can get
better than a two approximation
uh assuming some uh complexity results
yeah
okay good so
uh I'll just briefly mention some of the
applications of k-core decomposition so
um uh for these applications here
they're actually using k-core
approximately anyway so it's reasonable
to plug in an approximate k-core
algorithm
um so graph clustering Community
detection some of them use uh cornice
values graph visualization this is a
pretty intuitive example so you want to
basically be able to zoom in on
appropriate parts of your graph uh like
if you want to look at a dense part then
you zoom in there and then a k-core
decomposition will allow you to do that
efficiently but but this task is
approximate anyways so it's fine to use
an approximate decomposition here
um and then there are some other
applications like protein network
analysis and approximating the network
centrality
okay so the model that we're going to be
using to design and analyze our
algorithms is this works band model of
computation
so here the work is a number of
operations your algorithm does and the
span is the length of the longest
sequential uh dependence
and if you are able to get a work in a
span bound then you can upper bound the
running time of your algorithm by the
work divided by the number of processors
plus they go with the span and this
running time can be achieved using a
randomized work stealing scheduler so
you get this runtime in expectation
um if you get a if you use a greedy
scheduler you can actually get rid of
the Big O in front of this band but
greedy scheduling is Not Practical so uh
nobody uses that
okay so our goal is to come up with
lowest band parallel algorithms that are
also work efficient so work efficient
means that the work of the parallel
algorithm asymptotically matches the
best sequential algorithm for the same
problem
so we care about low span obviously
because we have the span term in the
running time
um but but we also care about work
efficiency because there's also a work
term in the running time
and in practice if you if you have an
algorithm that's reasonably low span
like poly logarithmic or even n to the
Epsilon for some small Epsilon then the
first term work over the number of
processors is going to dominate assuming
you're processing large data sets but
that's a reasonable assumption because
otherwise you wouldn't need parallelism
so therefore in practice the work
divided by number of processors is
usually going to dominate if you have a
reasonably low span so that's why we
want to try to reduce the work as much
as possible and the best you can do at
least asymptotically is to match the
sequential algorithm
so I'll give a summary of the results
that we're able to achieve
um so
we're able to get a parallel batch
Dynamic algorithm that maintains a two
plus Epsilon approximation
for the coordinates of every vertex
we show that a batch of B updates takes
order B log squared and amortized work
and uh poly logarithm expand with high
probability
and the algorithms work efficient
because the best sequential algorithm
for this problem takes order log squared
and amortized word per update and we're
doing B updates in order B log squared
and work okay
um we're algorithm is based on the
parallel level data structure which I'm
going to spend some time talking about
but before I want before I do that I
want to mention
the sequential level data structure
which uh I'll abbreviate as LDS and this
sequential level data structure was
described in previous work by bharatarya
hensing or nananka and Sarah caucus and
then also in another paper by hensinger
Newman uh Weiss
so in this data structure the vertices
are partitioned into order log squared
and different levels
these levels are further grouped into uh
groups of login levels order login
levels each
um and what we want to do is we want to
maintain certain invariants per vertex
um and these invariants have to do with
the up Neighbors of the vertex and an up
neighbor of a Vertex is roughly defined
to be the neighbors of the vertex at its
level or above in the data structure
there's some technicalities which I
don't want to get into but basically you
can just imagine the neighbors to be
vertices at the same level or above it
in the level data structure
and then variants say that we need to
have some upper and lower bounds on the
number of neighbors up Neighbors that
each vertex has so it can't have too
many but it also cannot have too few
and these thresholds are going to be
based on uh the group that the vertex is
on so each group has a different uh
different cutoff that we're going to use
for uh for these upper and lower bound
invariance
okay so later on I'll I'll talk about
how these group numbers translate to uh
good quartus estimates but I'm just
going to put that aside for now and tell
you how the level data structure works
Okay so
when your graph gets updated some of
these invariants for certain vertices
could be violated so if I add this red
Edge the yellow vertex now might have
too many up Neighbors
and in order to fix that I'm going to
move the vertex up so it loses that uh
that up neighbor and then now maybe it's
happy it doesn't have too many enables
and the same thing can happen when you
delete an edge so if I delete this
dashed red Edge the yellow vertex could
now have too few up Neighbors
so then I'm going to keep moving it down
until uh it has enough up Neighbors to
satisfy the invariance
so that's basically at a high level how
the sequential level data structure
works
um the actual implementation requires
you to like modify some data structures
efficiently but I'm going to sweep those
details under the rug
okay so there are some challenges with
paralyzing the sequential level data
structure
the first is that there could be these
large
sequential dependencies so there could
be these chains of movements so let's
say I move that yellow vertex down after
I delete the red Edge
it could actually cause its neighbor to
now have two too few up Neighbors so
then I need to move the neighbor down as
well and then that neighbor is going to
cause its neighbors to move down and we
get this chain effect where everybody is
basically moving down one at a time
um and this is not good for parallelism
uh it leads to an algorithm with large
span
um and then the second challenge is uh
well the sequential algorithm by
definition is only processing one of
data at a time
um but if we have a batch of updates we
want to try to do better than processing
each one at a time so those are the two
things that we're going to try to fix
with our parallel version of the level
data structure
any questions
um so our Parallel level data structure
which we call plds
supports batches of edge insertions or
batches of edge deletions
I'm going to focus on edge deletions
um insertions are similar but not
entirely symmetric and Quantum did talk
a little bit about insertions uh in her
talk so I'm going to focus on deletions
okay so the first thing to notice is
that when I delete edges only the lower
bound invariant can be violated so when
I delete edges vertices could could lose
up neighbors but they can never gain any
um and therefore
I only need to move vertices down to
make make sure that they're lower bound
invariant becomes satisfied again I
never need to move them up
Okay so
what we're going to do is for all the
vertices that are incident to these
edges that I delete
I'm going to check whether they're lower
bound invariant is violated if they are
then I'm going to compute what's called
a desire level which is the closest
level below them that they're such that
their lower bounding variant is
satisfied
so this example let's say the three
yellow vertices
are no longer satisfying their lower
bound invariant so that contributed this
desired level uh for these three yellow
vertices so the desired level is
basically the the closest level below
that satisfies invariance so the two
yellow vertices on level seven now want
to move to level five
um and then the yellow vertex at level
10 wants to move to level eight but is
that if you're moving them individually
without looking at anything else uh yeah
yeah
yeah so so the question was this is uh
is this the desire level uh assuming you
don't move anything else and the answer
is yes
um so that's why after we move some of
them you need to possibly recompute
this is our levels
Okay so
it's gonna iterate from the bottom most
level to the top and then for each level
that it looks at it's gonna see if
anybody wants to go there
so the first interesting level here is
level five there are two yellow vertices
I want to go there
so we're going to move them down to
level five in parallel
um we don't want to do them one at a
time because we want parallelism
and after we move them down
they could actually now cause some of
their neighbors to no longer be happy or
if one of the neighbors already had a
desired level maybe we need to update
that uh
so for this example let's just say that
uh this yellow vertex the one on the
left there before it was happy but now
it's not so now I compute a desired
level for it which is going to be six
and then let's say the other yellow
vertex which had a desired level of
eight I'll just keep that
so now when I get to level six I'm going
to move the yellow vertex uh at level
eight down to level six and I'm going to
check whether it's neighbor uh its
remaining up neighbor wants to move down
for this example let's just say it
doesn't
uh then when I get to level eight I'm
going to move that last vertex down so
now let's assume everybody has satisfied
their lower bound invariant and I'm done
okay so in the deletion algorithm every
vertex is going to move just once it's
going to move once to its uh uh to the
final desired level that it wants to go
to uh this is different from the
sequential LDS where if you were
processing the updates one at a time
each of the updates could cause a Vertex
to move down one level uh but for us for
a single batch each vertex is going to
move down uh just once to its final
level
okay
um so so let's go back to the question
about estimating these cornice values
so we set the corner assessment of a
Vertex to be 1 plus Delta to this messy
expression which you don't need to fully
understand but this exponent of the one
plus Delta is roughly equal to the group
number that the vertex is in so recall
that we we basically partitioned our
levels into log n groups each of log n
order log n levels
um and the exponent there is roughly
which group that the uh which group the
vertex belongs to
Okay so what this means is that vertices
that are higher up in the data structure
will have higher coordinates estimates
and intuitively this sort of makes sense
because a Vertex needs to be high up if
it has many neighbors who are also high
up and then if you look at the k-core
problem vertices that are in a k core
for a large value of K they have to have
a lot of neighbors who also have degree
at least K so that sort of corresponds
to our intuition that the vertices high
up in this data structure are likely to
be Parts a part of these uh dense cores
so we show that using this cornice
estimate equation you get a two plus
Epsilon approximation
um I'll I'll give some intuition about
how you prove the upper Bound for this
approximation on the next couple slides
and uh it turns out that getting better
than a two approximation is uh is p
complete meaning that it's unlikely you
can get a low span
parallel algorithm
um and this is because the the static
problem for k core is uh P complete
getting better than the two
approximation is p complete and if we
can if we can get a dynamic algorithm
that does better than two approximation
we can just use that to solve the static
Problem by giving all of the edges as a
single batch
okay um so let me give some intuition
about the upper bound proof so first we
need to think about this peeling process
which I mentioned earlier so if you're
trying to solve the k-core problem
statically
um you're gonna have this variable I
and then you're gonna delete this
variable I starts at one you're going to
delete all vertices with degree at most
I
you repeat this process until there are
no more such vertices and you increment
I uh to I plus one and you repeat and
then eventually the whole graph is going
to get removed and the time when you
remove a Vertex if it gets removed in
this round eye then you assign it a
coordinates value of I so that's how the
uh uh the static algorithm for k-core
works
okay so I'll recall that we set the
cornice estimate of a Vertex to be one
plus Delta to the I where I is
um roughly the group number
but also recall that we had these upper
and lower bounding variants so in
particular the upper bounding variant
says that
um you cannot have more than 2.1 times 1
plus Delta to the I up neighbors and 2.1
here is not very important it just has
to be some constant bigger than 2.
okay so let's look at this yellow vertex
here and imagine the peeling process so
if I'm peeling the vertices from the
graph well I'm going to get rid of the
ones that are lower down first
and then eventually I'm going to get rid
of all the neighbors of the yellow
vertex that are below it
um and then when I do when I peel off
this yellow vertex by definition its
core number is going to be upper bounded
by its up degree at this point but we
also have that the up degree is upper
bounded by 2.1 times 1 plus Delta to the
I so therefore we also get that the core
number of this yellow vertex is upper
bounded by 2.1 so the uh 2.1 times 1
plus Delta to the I we gave in an
estimate of 1 plus Delta to the I so
this is a 2.1 approximation uh it's just
one-sided
uh if you want to prove the other side
meaning that uh you want to show that
the true core number is not too much
smaller than the estimate
the proof is more complicated but it
also uh uses this peeling process so the
high level idea is that
assume that the core number was
way smaller than the core the true core
number was a lot smaller than the
estimate uh the algorithm gave then we
can sort of do this peeling process and
then we we peel off vertices and it
turns out that before we get to the
yellow vertex the whole graph is gone
and this leads to a contradiction
um so I'm not going to go over the
technical details for that but I'm happy
to chat offline or uh also refer you to
the paper
um okay any questions before I talk
about implementations yeah so what was
known before your work is you said the
like the data structure was invented
previously right
so in terms of the impossible yeah so
the data structure was invented
previously
um the authors did not use it to solve
the k-core problem it was used for uh
densis subgraph
um as well as graph coloring if I
remember yeah
okay
um
so implementation details so we we
implemented this algorithm uh for
multi-core machines
we use parallel Primitives and data
structures from this graph based
Benchmark Suite that my collaborators
and I worked on a couple years ago
um
how do we store the neighbors of these
vertices in the data structure so
we use concurrent hash tables to store
the neighbors and for a given vertex V
we have one concurrent hash table to
store its neighbors at or above its
level
whether we have a separate hash table
for every level I below the level of V
to store its neighbors at that
particular level so you might wonder why
this is not symmetric here
well the reason is that in our data
structure we have a bound on the number
of up Neighbors that a Vertex has but we
don't have a bound on the number of
non-up labors or down neighbors so to
speak
so our hashtag over storing the up
Neighbors is going to be bounded in size
but if we were to store all of the
neighbors below us in a single hash
table that hash table would just be uh
too big and when we're doing operations
on the data structure things would not
be work efficient so that's why it's not
symmetric here
okay so
um oh yes question
uh
you know aware of this but this is a
data structure
um
actually uh from
I don't know 15 years ago right then I'm
going to help him yeah
that works in the algorithmic number of
grounds it gives basically the same
result
and they're clocking around you can get
this
level data structure yeah so what was
that used
distributed Mis and the following a
bunch of things in boundaries I see yeah
I mean I think we we looked at that but
if I recall correctly like the the bound
it gave us was not exactly what we
wanted
um
but I it was a while ago maybe
yeah exactly the structure for
um
same
yeah is that data structure for
computing the maximum Rubber City over
the course of all updates where is it
for the current operator today
and the goal of this algorithm is to
compute such 11 data structure but they
don't conflict
because if they're not maintaining
anything
limit in logarithmic number of
program
aware of distilled algorithms this is
why I'm mentioning it it might be worth
checking
yeah thanks for that yeah cool yeah
we'll check it out I think we looked at
that I don't I don't remember exactly
what the conclusion was but yeah thanks
for pointing that out
um cool any other questions
okay um okay so so like moving these
vertices around in the plds like moving
them up and down levels it requires us
to carefully update these hash tables in
parallel
um uh and also for work efficiency
okay um
let me just briefly go over the
complexity analysis
um the span is easy and the work is
complicated so uh I'll talk mostly about
the span
um and then I'll give you some intuition
for the work analysis so the data
structure has order log squared n number
of levels
and recall that in our batch deletion
algorithm we need to compute these
desire levels which is the closest level
below it that satisfies the lower
bounding variant so we basically use a
doubling search here so we check one
level below two four eight and so on
until we get to a level that does
satisfy the lower bounding variant and
then we do a binary search within the
last interval so it's order log of the
number of levels which is order log log
n uh span for each level
and then for the hash table operations
we just uh plug in a black box result so
you can do everything in order log star
and span
with high probability so this gives us a
total span of order log squared and log
log n with high probability
um the the workbound
um we got order B Times log squared and
amortize work for a batch of uh B
Updates this is based on a potential
argument uses a very similar analysis to
the bharacharya hensing or the nankai
sura caucus paper from 2015. uh we made
some slight modifications but the high
level ideas is the same and the vertices
and edges here are storing potentials
based on their levels
uh in the plds and these potentials are
going to be used to pay for the cost of
moving vertices up and down
one thing that we need to do is we need
to argue that the operations that we're
doing in parallel can be mapped to an
equivalent set of sequential operations
uh and once we do that then we can
basically just reuse the sequential
analysis there
okay experiments um so we ran
experiments on two types of Google Cloud
instances for the first one is a 30 core
machine with two-way hyper threading
with a 236 gigabytes of primary we also
use the larger machine with 48 cores and
to a hyper threading with over a
terabyte of memory we only use the
larger machine for some of the larger
graphs I needed it uh since I didn't
want to pay that much for running using
it for all the graphs this is a lot more
expensive the second instance
um so we test on three different types
of batches uh insertions deletions as
well as mixed batches of both insertions
and deletions the results were pretty
similar so I'm just going to present the
results for the Mixed batch setting
okay so we uh compared four different
implementations
um plds is the algorithm I just
described plds opt is a optimized
version of plds where we tweak some of
the parameters such that we no longer
got a two plus Epsilon approximation the
approximation was a bit higher but it's
a lot faster
um and then as for existing work uh
White all presented a parallel exact
dynamic algorithm for this problem and
Sun it all presented a sequential
approximate Dynamic algorithm for this
problem and as far as we know there is
no other algorithm that's parallel and
approximate
um uh for dynamic k-core besides plds
okay so here
um we're plotting the average time per
batch versus the average error so we're
averaging over the errors for all the
vertices in the graph in terms of their
quartus estimates
on the left we have dblp which is a
small graph with about 2 million edges
on the right we have live Journal which
is a larger graph of 85 million edges
um okay so the the two axes are in log
log scale here uh so first uh we can
look at Hua so why is this black line
the reason why it's a flat line here is
because it's an exact algorithm so it
doesn't incur any error so we just care
about the running time
the blue dots correspond to plds opt the
rad ones correspond to plds and then the
green corresponds to the Sun at all
implementation
so one thing to notice is that if we if
we fix the average error that one of the
blue dots achieves it actually gets the
fastest running time across the
implementation so for a given error uh
that plds opt is able to achieve it gets
the best performance however note that
the plds and Sun implementations are
able to achieve a slightly better errors
than PL DSR because as I said plds up
change some of the parameters so that we
don't have the two plus Epsilon
guarantee but actually in practice the
the pldsop implementation is able to get
errors as low as uh uh 1.25 x so this is
already better than the two plus Epsilon
approximation guarantee that plds and
Sun are able to achieve
yes
I mean you mentioned that it's difficult
to parallelize the exact algorithm so
what do what I call it so this is a uh
this is not a theoretical result so
their algorithm actually has linear span
per update
um they get a little bit of speed UPS in
practice which I'll talk about in the
next I think in two slides after this
yes what is the approximation ratio that
sonnet oil achieved yeah yeah so sonnet
also get a two plus Epsilon
approximation yeah both update time do
they have sequently yeah it's locked
order log squared and amortized per
update and they proved the approximation
ratio independent of your approximation
ratio uh yeah yeah so so they in their
proof we actually found uh
a slight slight mistake which uh it was
kind of hard to fix so we came up with a
different proof yeah
what kind of best out there that you did
oh sorry
yeah good so
um so we we tested on uh uh graphs a
whole bunch of real world crafts some of
them had a temporal order to them uh
meaning that the edges had time stamps
on them so for for those we just
processed the edges in the time CM order
and then for the other graphs which
didn't have time stamps on the edges we
just like uh randomized the edges and
then uh generated batches based on that
from if they're a theoretical guarantee
for
is there a theoretical guarantee for
this pld assault you said it's like
slightly worse than
I mean it's actually I I think it's
actually a lot worse that it is bounded
by some uh constant but I don't remember
what it is right now but it's
be a lot worse than the two plus hours
um Okay so
overall we're able to get like two to
three orders of magnitude uh speed up
over uh Sun at all
um sun sun sun at all is sequential so
it's part of the speed UPS just come
from being parallel but we also get
additional speedups just from uh better
optimizations in our implementation
and then compared to the exact parallel
algorithm before at all we get
um uh up to 25x speed up
um okay so here are the scalability
results so here we're varying the number
of hyper threads and looking at the
average time per batch
um plds opt-in plds scale pretty well
sun is sequential so it's flat as
expected uh why it all actually like
they get a little bit of speed ups but
uh not much um and the reason is because
exact k-core is hard to paralyze uh they
have some BFS DFS process in their
implementation which is uh uh it can be
very
um it could have very high span uh uh in
many cases
okay so uh overall our our soft router
parallel speed ups are pretty good
um 33x for plds up on average PL uh plds
gets about 26x on average
before it only gets a little over 3x
okay and the plds implementation is is
faster than all the other algorithms
when you just use four or more cores
we also looked at runtime versus batch
size
um and again pldsoft is able to get the
fastest performance uh across all of the
different batch sizes
um
okay and we get between 2.5 and over
100x speed up over the white all
implementation
we also compared the runtime of the
batch Dynamic algorithm to parallel
static algorithms for k-core
um uh the first one is an exact
algorithm that my collaborators and I
worked on uh many years ago and then in
this paper we also came up with a two
plus Epsilon approximate uh K Port
decomposition algorithm which is static
and also parallel
um so here I'm looking at the speed UPS
of the batch Dynamic algorithm over the
static one using a batch size of 10 to
the six the graphs here are ordered by
size from left to right smallest to
largest
and we we see that we get speed ups for
almost all of the graphs so for all of
them except the the two smaller graphs
YouTube and uh dblp for the smaller
graphs it turns out that the number of
edges they have is not too much larger
than the batch size so in that case it
actually makes sense to just rerun the
static algorithm but once you get to
larger graphs like Twitter and
Friendster with over a billion edges
this batch size of 10 to the six is
pretty small compared to that so we're
able to get speed UPS of over 100x
okay so let me conclude
um uh I talked about theoretically
efficient impractical batch Dynamic k
core decomposition algorithm uh using
the plds we are also able to get
parallel batch Dynamic algorithms for
several other problems so low outcoming
orientation is sort of a a trivial
corollary of the level data structure
but we also looked at Maxwell matching
uh clay counting and graph coloring well
the graph coloring result is a
paralyzation of a recent paper by
hensinger at all
um the the source code is available
online if anyone's interested in uh
checking it out
um and that's it
[Applause]
so actually I have one question are your
data sets available somewhere publicly
these graphs that you used yeah so the
data sets um they come from this
Stanford network analysis repository so
they are publicly available we just
downloaded graphs from that website
thank you and the way you made them
Dynamic is as you sketched so you don't
have a specific repository for the
dynamic versions of the graphs that you
used uh no so so like for the data sets
that had the control information on them
we just used that like uh this
information was up in snap and then for
the other ones we just randomized the
order of the edges
there's a dumb question but oh
I mean since my my little familiarity
with this there's these people in
database world who have like really
honed the sequential static algorithm
approximation uh have you run it against
sequential non-dynamic
um you know static algorithms oh
sequential yeah we have compared with
that but unfortunately I don't I don't
remember the results off the top of my
head like we when we came up with the
parallel static k-core algorithm like
many years ago we compared with the
static one uh I don't think like our
single threaded time was too too much
off from the new ones too right sorry
new ones oh there are new ones yeah
um
I yeah I I haven't looked at the new
ones but if I mean if you can send me a
pointer that would be great I'd be
interested in taking a look yeah
other questions
no so thank you very much again all
right thank you
[Applause]